if you do wrong things mainly harming
other you get negative consequences as
some says and the good person some say
bad person that doesn't matter solo my
own motivation or thinking is honest
since then when we investigate the
reality our mind should be calm basis of
genuine friendship is trust Trust depend
on openness he's a monk of the yellow
hat school of Tibetan Buddhism
he's currently the 14th dalai lama in
1989 he received the Nobel Peace Prize
he's a dalai lama and here is my take on
his top ten rules for success rule
number two is my personal favorite and
i'm curious to see which one you guys
like the best as always as the dalai
lama speaking if he says something
that's really inspiring to you make sure
to leave it in the comments below and
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well
[Music]
it's an ultimate source of satisfaction
within also if you do wrong things
mainly harming other you get negative
consequences if you do helping other
bring more happiness to other you get
benefit more inner strength there and
more sort of confidence of purpose of
life and fulfillment about that purpose
then you always feel happy if the rest
of the people really feel me as a
politician furthermore bad politicians
and I feel sad or cutting career a
cunning liar politician dent and of
course no problem the problem a son says
I'm the good person some say bad person
that doesn't matter soul of my own
motivation for thinking is honest since
a that's it that's important that's
simple Buddhist monks actually easy but
that is you thought don't care how
others are the same if you once said too
much praise then at that time should
think or I also have the critics and
then once says it did a lot of criticism
then you should think or some people
praising me this so doesn't matter too
much though because of the pay much
attention
these things are silly ultimate source
of happy life is our inner value so
therefore irrespective whether believer
or non-believer whether believer
religion or not see we should pay more
attention about our inner value now
scientists lost according latest to
scientific findings
it now sort of clear even good health or
healthy body the healthy mind is very
essential more peaceful mind brings
healthy body because mind calm peaceful
then our healthy our body sort of
element also you see then remain more
balanced so that brings healthy body and
trauma stress toward you worry disturb
our body element that creates certain
sort of problems about this body
so therefore our mind is very essential
I think you should realize the anger may
bring some kind of energy a short moment
a short period but that energy is
actually blind energy and anger really
destroy your positive part of your brain
which can judge the right or wrong so
when we fully sorrow develop anger we
can't see the reality so that energy
more bold red but that energy is blind
by energy so the in order to face the
problem our method should be as I
mentioned earlier realistic in order to
carry realistic method you must know the
reality when we look the reality when we
investigate the reality our mind should
be calm
otherwise we cannot see the thing
objectively so in order to use human
intelligence properly our mind should
become so thinking is like anger they
say firstly destroy your inner peace
secondly destroy your ability to to
investigate the reality so you think
this line then once you have period sort
of awareness
anger is no use only destruction
affection or compassionate attitude or
hardness there is very very important
for one's own well-being one's own
happiness so don't consider practice of
compassion is something religious matter
or practice of compassion is something
good for other not necessarily to
oneself that's a totally mistake
so since from childhood we already
equipped this seed of compassion we
learned from mother and ourself in order
to become parent they deceived already
there now that's it
you must keep nurture whole our life the
biological factor compassion is limited
biased and more depend on others
attitude now dad has a seed then using
reasons awareness dad seed compassion or
can develop can further develop unbiased
compassion not based on not depend on
others attitude but
other others being itself so that kind
of compassion can reach your enemy or
entire sentient being so that compassion
is infinite compassion unbiased
compassion real compassion so if you
become compassionate person then your
life becomes meaningful because you
yourself happy calm peacefully your
friend or including animals also see get
peace so at the last day of our life
you feel happy now hold my life I'll
spend peaceful friendly you really feel
happy otherwise at that moment even your
be linear those money nothing can be
used no matter what so good cause of the
good body a beautiful body all
everything have to doesn't have to leave
so at that time I think Jenny's
satisfaction can bring if your whole
life spend more compassionate life than
you feel or no regret so that was a life
is naturally happy life meaningful life
so in order to make meaningful life
ultimately ohm hardness is the key
factor then another important factor is
determination
and you should not think the city's
development can take place within a few
days or few years we must understand you
see that these development even may take
eons
so if they are determination if you've a
so they consider as a Buddhist and and
want to really practice about the Dharma
then the right upon the beginning you
must be see make up your mind or doesn't
matter even may take millions of Bills
Bills of yawns doesn't matter today the
what's a day after all what is the
purpose of her life the meaning of
existence nothing you realize something
positive then even you see days and
mundo y it is meaningful if you're
really wasting our life purpose all life
then even one day too long so once you
determined once you make up your mind
some kind of firm determination and
clarity to pay now and then time is not
important so they're like a shadow
deficit or one of you see where they
store long space with me so long
sentient beings considered something
remain I will be in order to serve this
death sentence relieves it gives me
something to intercept and all by the
inspiring so the more for them is the
impatience and as I mentioned before you
City want something is a quickest on
that's or something then I can reserve
also poorest act
the cheapest method quickest cheapest
method yourself will be poorest so is it
though so is it that something wrong so
that I would like to share with you so
that's why is it
I myself orders he recited some mantra
or some visualization is a certain
mandalas but mine in my daily practice
although my practice very poor very poor
but even then see there I'm is a main
emphasis on this fall over truth and put
the cheetah and corona so that's really
I feel it is something better than then
through these practice you will get
something practical benefit realizations
big deities sometimes I think they
keeping oneself almost almost is like
ggd oneself at the ceiling once
receiving once you see one oneself so
therefore I think we must be subtractors
step by step and with patience with the
determination once you involve or
dedicated or determine practice then
some improvement you can see is a year
by your declared by at least decade by
decade then you can see or at least a
some change some some improvement you
can see once you once you see that that
also she gives you gives you some kind
of a new encouragement so she change and
not easy not easy when we feel certain
sort of irritation during that moment if
that person also take fully on the
breathing nothing else and breathing one
two three like five ten fifteen twenty
when you start breathing minister
irritated
but then after 2030 are basing your
mental state will be a little different
little mocha since we are dealing with
emotions so the best method to deal with
that is so the so called meditation not
for next life not for heaven but is it
for day two days well being do you
believe that your time on here on earth
has been a success success oh that also
relative some field I feel some
achievement there and some feed failure
so difficult to say I Hill all human
life like that
some part failure somebody achieve it is
wrong to pick up one thing then say or
very success is wrong and pick up one
thing or failure that also wrong things
are relative
we are social animal we human being
social animal and particularly modern
time the reality economy environment and
many things heavily interdependent
there's the reality unlike I think past
the sort of as the ancient time innocent
I am more less independent
self-sufficient this is not depend your
interest not not your interest or your
future not depend on other now
completely change so even from this
selfish viewpoint you have to take care
about others will be you just think
yourself oh the blind selfish can be
yourself forget other or worse thing
exploit other cheating other bully other
ultimately you suffer through these
mischievous way you may gain some
temperature sort of benefit but in deep
insight you feel uncomfortable then
eventually you truly become a lonely
person
nobody loves you nobody respect you if
you take care other as a human brother
sisters sincerely ah seriously
then everybody become your friend so
when you have truly trusted friend there
if you need something you can ask if
you'd becoming friendless a lonely
person and when you really facing some
problems nobody you can share so
ultimately we are social animal so even
other animal no law no education no
religion but you see they have some kind
of sort of feeling their own individual
survival depend on rest of the community
or hurts so they work together I am one
of the individual out of a seven billion
human being if human being rest of the
human being had be peaceful
I get maximum benefit the rest of the
world get trouble how can I escape from
that and with that feeling when I meet
people one or two or one people or one
person or ten people one hundred
thousand ten thousand hundred thousand I
always answer them as my brother sisters
that brings me in mental level
completely relaxed if I feel I'm
something different from them
then some nervousness stop anxiety may
develop so once your own way of thinking
open result them as a close friend that
tremendous sort of benefit is our mind
then others also feel no longer feel
stranger another human brothers like
that so that I think visually nowadays
we really need that so through that way
awareness then from children I think the
answers I think they know they just one
child remain lonely may cry and play
with other children feel very happy so
there's a human nature so sometimes we
grown up then we always calculate if I
make friend friendship with that how
much I get some benefit or make
friendship then I can exploit or
something then then genuine basis of
friendship no longer de destroyed basis
of genuine friendship is trust trust
depend on openness like that so through
these things we can train and then
mental level no matter what your
physical level busy what mental level
always calm restful relaxed immense
benefit for your health so mental health
body health very close link so the
ultimate source of mental health is all
hotness that's my belief
may be wrong my friend have to research
more research work when I was here I
have some different birds so one small
parrot
see my one of the day official say feed
that parrot so therefore whenever that
the person approach to that sort of at
parent the parent or agency showing some
very excite excitement or some like that
then the official does it give some nuts
and then while the parrot is eating
depended the official finger Z on the on
depth on the head as a parent coli that
then the terror is showing special sort
of the friendly attitude so I developed
some jealousy so I also want that kind
of response from their parent so I'm
dilemma so therefore we say the must
show you see more so they're friendly so
for animal you see do not know that so
in any way I try to deviled egg and as a
friendship so a few days I try to give
some nuts then that Barrett take the nut
then showing very negative attitude then
I lost my temper I use something stick
to discipline disciplinary action so
after that no hope
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Saren Cho esto I
hope I pronounced that okay asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I also love to know which
of the top 10 rules had the biggest
impact on you and why what change you're
going to make in your life for business
after watching this video leave it in
the comments hold yourself accountable
and I'm going to join in the discussion
as well thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
the important thing is that a flipped
emotions already flipped emotion yes
the ultimate is an enemy or the source
of suffering and and also there is that
is a filter emotion once it develop
within our mind immediately is it
destroyer or peace of mind and they
eventually destroy our health and also
the destroy our friendship with other
people so all is the negative activities
such as killing bling cheating all these
negative actions this will come out of
this fatigue motion so is it that they
really enemy
that's the destroyer of our peace
destroy our our cause of the fortune and
including our health so therefore that's
the enemy really external enemy today
may be harmful to you but dense they
maybe they have but this is inner enemy
always remain sa destructive and
moreover that enemy wherever you live
always there that's reading the external
enemy we can put some loosen difference
of your summation yet it on all Susie la
cosa 59 we escaped so you say we can we
can ask but there is this this enemy
even when I interpret over in potala
were they in dance Allah when I'm
hearing it in London enemy wherever I go
this Anna media
even I think some somewhere of
meditation somewhere early today the
visualization of Mandela still in the
very center of the Mandela that enemy is
still there so this is the point now we
have to realize that now the coz so you
see they they really destroy of our
happiness always there how to do now if
there is what say no possible if this or
no possibility look to overcome that to
eliminate that then I think better
forget and I think older I think relying
more alcohol sets all these things much
better if there is possibility is it to
eliminate that then I think now we must
take is visible to opportunity this is
human body human brain human good heart
combine these two things try is it to
reduce that and eventually eliminate so
therefore is a Buddhist recordable is
teaching or human body is precious
why because of human intelligence and it
is shaping or the change in our mind not
only through emotion but many feelings
or intelligence reasoning and there are
programs of emotion one emotion without
any reason just as a faith such as a
hatred or these things of course the
absolution sub reasons while this person
is aware as order Hanuman me and them
through their kind is analyzed is your
double painted but in deep down and
further goes is not what you see reasons
so it is easy motion without it without
proper color reasons that's the negative
emotion and the other kind of emotion
such as compassion actress a kind of
emotion but with reasons and a further
investigate you can prove that something
good
something necessary something useful so
they're gonna be motion is ordered type
of emotion but very much relatively very
much go well with liens or inter
intelligence
so they combination intelligence and
emotion that's the way to change to
change our or in a world so that also I
think they did diversity they the basic
fundamental the suckling nature
suffering nature so long dad any media
solo we are under that enemies control
no permanent happiness so once you
develop some kind of suit came desire to
overcome that enemy now that is the
titanium so that is call that is the
true realization the expedition to seek
freedom main junior user which is
technically called renunciation in in
the Buddhist language so so you see the
distractors the analyze our emotional
level and our inner inner world is the
very important is the key the key
practice then I think the best method to
avoid fear or regret at the time of
death is while we are alive our time our
energy must utilize meaningful way serve
another decisive the most profound civil
right way of a meaning of usefulness
once on Survivor even animals also you
can do but for service to other is
something unique about human being I
think bondage way the mother and child
or offspring the bond the bond between
mother honestly even other animals also
have but there are so that kind of cross
the feeling short period but we
shouldn't be because of intelligence
that kind of feeling we can prolong
whole our life ex yeah extended travel
ah so serving other people helping other
people is that I think very very
appropriate sort of action according our
intelligence way or human ability we
have such an ability so then utilize
that ability Posada in the most
appropriate way of most appropriately is
seven other people then at the end you
feel no regret I done my best some
useful some meaningful life now and come
out of sorry sad but no regret so mentor
level experience and sensory level
experience mental level experience are
much more serious
obviously we've been we can further vxb
ourself paucity have experienced when
our mental state happy hum of physical
pain can subdue when mental state to
explain too much worry the physical
comfort cannot reduce rah cannot subdue
the mental state sorrow pain so
obviously mental state is more serious
so therefore
now including medical science mon amour
now scientists in that field now realize
mental state is very very important for
our health so resistant for our meeting
with scientists our slogan
how to how to create healthy body
healthy mind so healthy mind very much
little bit has the body so healthy mind
is it can reproduce by medicine or
alcohol or drugs no Oh more illusions
rare oh sorry
so healthy mind also you cannot cannot
produce by injection cannot buy from
supermarket so they are for the healthy
mind must develop within the mind from
faith some extent but no the real change
in mental level certain conviction
genuine conviction come only through
research investigation